[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
uh
oh
outside
all right
oh
[Music]
what
while alone
at this time we have to turn off all
cell phones and please refrain from any
photography we also have to be refrained
from heckling the comedians during the
performance and now we are proud to
present your house for the evening
thank you guys welcome to other people a
dating show where we make people date
whether they want to or not
uh my name is hans kim coming to you
live from austin texas on mother's day
we're about to make some mothers tonight
and hopefully
these men can play their cards right am
i late ladies
men are trash
uh my name is hans kim i was recently
mentioned on joe rogan you might know me
from kill tony pretty big deal uh i am
off the market i actually have a
girlfriend
this
as a supporter
phil tommy watcher well this girl is
almost a complete ripoff of kill tony so
you'll enjoy it
uh we got people dating they go on a
date for one minute and then we
interview them uh find them find them a
more interesting thing to say find out
more about them i have a guest on this
show uh very talented hilarious comedian
you might have seen her on kill tony
give it up for heather keith
good to see you on this podcast
yeah
[Music]
you don't get drunk like you did on my
other podcast oh my god can you actually
delete that
that was embarrassing no i'm sober
friend for a day
yeah we uh actually did rail from
cocaine
yeah
it's not drink it's less calories
so
yeah uh we're gonna have a great time
today or we're gonna watch people date
on a seat for elijah and you just set
this up for one day when a gay person is
brave enough
they have a bucket just for that thank
you hopefully they're asexual
um
the band
oh my god what does that say
a woman
yui
[Applause]
[Music]
you can sign up anytime during the show
we need more women
i think we only got two left
so
there's also stairs right around the
corner but uh
[Music]
how are you doing
what's going on
let me see here where are you from
uh i'm from austin i've been here for
about seven years how are you doing i'm
from dallas fort worth but i've been
here from san diego so everybody speaks
some from california
i was born in san diego new york yeah
where uh
san diego trade city
um
i do fire spinning with friends for fun
yeah
it's we have it's somebody else's we
have props and you can light them up
and we do a bunch of shenanigans with
them and sometimes it's unsafe
yeah
yeah like a tlc couple that's looking
for their starter home you know
i love it
that's for sad families
healthy babies
yeah
wow and you're from california where are
you from
[Music]
i actually just looked at dallas fort
worth but i went back and forth from
california san diego
oh nice the oc yeah so you are not
vaccinating addiction
you guys both have very pretty faces
it's insane
yeah
baby they're so smooth and clean and
i look like me
and all it says in her nose right now is
big small talk
they had six small talk traffic crazy
this is pink whiteness right here yeah
um
you guys do look like domain people
of course you did
i'm facilitating this might be the first
date on the show that actually takes off
you guys look like the same tax
graduates yeah
you're in the blue
wait what do you guys did you guys
already talked about your jobs
oh
wait what was the explosion that you
just had fire spinning you don't fire
spin as a job
i checked out what
what are your jobs
okay
not the same tax bracket at all
she
she eats free snacks he [ __ ] is
looking into a tesla
yeah what family do you mean for last
name and
[Music]
oh that's one of the better hills
yeah i stay in my bubble gas is
expensive
i'm not going outside my bubble
yeah
wait what
uh most recently like four years
four years yeah so you're here
pre-pandemic yeah for sure so you you
didn't come here for the freedoms
[Music]
yeah
no regrets hello yeah you fit right in
you ever been paddleboarding
no
actually i wanna i wanna date here we
were gonna go come on
[Music]
done [ __ ] up
emmy you got to step it up if you want
to leave with him
what else
yeah come coddle me
no i'm fine but yeah later
i was gonna say she's very fairy like
you look like a character in like the
dark crystal you guys
what a movie
yeah
gay
i get it
yeah i was like don't take the show
seriously
so what uh how did you meet your day
tonight
on uh
you were like you want to go out and
watch me date other people
okay cool
i'm gonna be dating another man this is
gonna be great i really do hope you guys
leave with someone else tonight
[Laughter]
where do you take your days on days
[Music]
like walks i don't know like that kind
of stuff this is actually the cool thing
i've been on
the restaurant
uh cool i was guessing more buffalo wild
wings with you but
that's where it works
yeah swear to where it's at
that's awesome you know all the cool
spots you got your
nice short sleeve black dress shirt
uh what the so where do you work you can
you tell us where you work software
engineer
if it's recorded no
so facebook he works for facebook
they're the most
they're the most uh shitty one of all
the tech
stuff uh emmy uh so have you ever been
on a date with a tech bro before
wow what a surprise
this town is full of those
bags
easily five or six
five or six
you must have only been here two months
are you yeah
are you on are you on the apps
little appies
no no you get enough action as a nanny
from the dad
i'm done for a while
uh when was your last date
probably a couple months ago how was it
it's good
tell us about your worst date
oh
um
we went out for bubble tea on like
riverside and we were just not hitting
it off and i had to go to work which was
nice because i had like a time to like
escape uh-huh except it turned out he
parked in a spot that was clearly gonna
be towed uh-huh and he's like oh
can you like drive me to the tow truck i
just really need help i need to go to
this parking lot i was like i gotta go
to work and he's like
you gotta help me i started like crying
on the side
john s
i'm glad you didn't cry that's you're
doing better than this guy me too
oh that's yeah i was gonna say this is
sounding like a very boring like most
most women's bad dates ended murder but
yeah
just in tears so that's cool
you didn't give him a ride you just left
him in the dust
oh that's so nice you should have been
like uber exists [ __ ] also wine
scooters
like who the [ __ ] why do you hear me
crying start punching him
yeah he can't read street signs
emotionally unstable yeah
science i said we will tell you if you
park here and this car was right
underneath it must have been from san
diego if you know what i mean
uh and you made it to work on time
oh that poor child
is left alone with a stove and an
electrical socket
um that's uh that's pretty sad you know
everyone loves a damsel in distress but
no one loves a dude in distress
that's not sexy at all
oh help
what a [ __ ]
it's mother's day but no one wants to be
a [ __ ] mom
yeah we're not trying to mother
men we're trying to mother little little
tiny babies
that's great you're practicing you know
the mothering process
would you hey uh john s would you ever
have children
yeah i want kids oh
what a christian yeah
what those genetics yeah sure
what about you emmy you want kids
no
cool she's cool
why not
i love kids but i love being able to
have a life so i get to be a nanny and
like
experience that and then give them back
to their parents and get a good night's
sleep that is you're micro dosing
motherhood
what a job
you're a tourist
and parenthood
that's awesome well thank you guys so
much for going on a date you guys are
very beautiful people give it up for
them
john s and mec
going on a date
we only have one more woman left so
we know who this is the john s's date
right now coming up
but uh if any women want to sign up we
need you grow some balls we're gonna
have uh dudes go on dates with each
other yeah
no one wants to see that
another woman
hell yeah all right we got simon coming
up john s's date
and the man coming up picked by our very
own heather keith i don't know on
instagram
i can't wait
wait
that's a woman
pandas you signed up in the wrong bucket
no need to worry john
and go
it says um oh it's a big it's a big one
did you see that movie uh this
no
like
about the soccer tournament in south
africa
should i watch it that's great yeah it's
great it says i think whatever god's me
conquerable soul i'm the master of my
fate i'm the captain of my soul wow
that's really long more personally hurt
like a [ __ ] but it's good i like
it i thought is that your only tattoo
nope i have one here
you got some ink huh you got some ink
yeah i have one around here it's
beautiful does he know about that
i think so uh my eyebrows are also
tattooed on
my fiance will feel much better that i
went on a date with a girl i asked him
if i could do this nice ring too though
thank you is this your first date with
him this is her second day oh okay he
made it to round two damn you cannot see
anybody can't say hi oh my god
okay okay and time give it up for simon
candice
i love the old point out your other date
on a date move
and point out your fiance that's fine
is he not he's engaged
well i'm here from missouri actually or
misery if you'd like to call it that you
know that movie where she beats him on
the legs yeah
very accurate so that's how you got
engaged
what's that stockholm syndrome where
they have that yeah he has stockholm
syndrome as well you got a tattoo from a
movie that i not a lot of people have
seen tree and i loved that poem so yeah
and i love nelson mandela i mean cool
dude right is that all about kathy bates
movie it is so much fun
is it
get crazy
you know i've seen that new show she's
in disjointed that's all about weed it's
like my favorite one
netflix you should watch it's funny it
looks cheesy no but still it's just cool
to see people in unexpected roles like
this date yeah
two women thought you guys wanted us to
put it in what we liked so i put it in
men need to be more clear
i learned all kinds of new ones because
my friend also signed up
what did we learn about like there's
just all kinds of weird well not not
weird i i respect everybody's you know
kink whatever but there's just lots of
different scriptures for what you like
in terms of like
fetishes holly well it's not those are
like those are ones i've heard there's
just all kinds of open a hinge account
let's see your hinge it tells you it's
all kinds out there you don't have poly
people in missouri oh of course we do we
don't have a lot of other people it's
like a sprinkle of black and the only
black person from missouri is here
tonight give it up for candid
thank you
but i used to live in florida so i'm
here with my friends in florida oh nice
it is florida peeps over there why do
you why do you live here this is devil
hot i thought florida was bad it's very
hot yeah texas is hot yes
we get pretty hot here dre is the answer
okay
taken is the answer
oh yeah right right right are we going
to tell them where's your taken tattoo
oh okay
straight
i i'm straight yeah a hundred percent
tall i don't remember all these women
are beautiful
i was to say you guys can both take emmy
home tonight
and he seems very
cool yeah
so emmy uh what do you do for a living
that's not emmy
into text sales so i'm entry level
check bro you can sell your tech bro
huh you can sell he can make it and you
can sell it you guys are a power couple
yeah so i can
well our first date kind of i was asking
him what he does and what some tech
terms mean so for basically yeah
yeah you're like let me see if this
guy's for real does he have a good job
yeah
oh
that's why you're dating him
i mean it matters yeah he's a very
successful handsome
little dude and it's going well
yeah
third date huh third date coming around
well i'll have to ask him but i would be
down i mean not if candice has her way
she's ready to get in the way i feel
like you're more of an alpha than john s
wants
you're damn right
he's a powerful black woman
i'm just fifty she does not wait for the
second date to slip a finger
i'm a lady have you ever have you ever
played with your fiance's butthole no he
is he was very clear when we started
dating that that was not allowed
that's a lot of stuff i'm from the
midwest so kind of know what a cold
you're not actually holding the [ __ ]
what is it
it's what john s is about to do tonight
watch right isn't that gonna launch in
the closet dress like superman
i said i don't know what that means but
i am not about it unmatched so no no
butt stuff no butts okay with that how
do you really know who someone is if you
haven't played around with their
butthole i mean i've seen his butt
plenty of times but i just don't like
he's just no booty hole that's never
gone in the chocolate highway oh i don't
like strap-ons and things like that it's
not my jam okay yeah you don't even have
a vibrator
uh i do now yeah she has a vibrator yeah
female empowerment
do you have
i do not have a vibrator
does not
it just no she does not [ __ ] me in the
ass
she's been exploring around that region
she has yet to uh you know go down the
tunnel but i'm happy for your arms
shaver i support everyone's kinks you
should be kink respectful yeah
have you played with a man's [ __ ]
before
i know
you refused
her for pooping
[Laughter]
uh
not even after like a shout out
like you like redstone what are you guys
missionaries
yeah what's uh
what's the freakiest thing you've done
with john s
go on a second date again
they're
they're too hot and respectable to have
had sex
yeah but i trust me i know but
no you guys should totally [ __ ] yeah um
where would you go would you go to his
house or your house
probably his house is probably better he
lives too far
he visits the domain
yeah that's not where you want to go to
[ __ ]
the domain isn't for [ __ ] that's for
dating that's for getting away from
homeless
people yeah you need a couple homeless
people if you want to [ __ ] correctly
you got to have them listening in
uh no that's fine that's great uh you
guys are on a date and you you think
it's gonna you think he's the one
i believe in the ones i don't know
multiple people he's polyamorous
she's one of those paulie
i don't share
a little bit of john has a little bit of
candace the hinge option it's a hinge
option
i love that i don't believe in the one i
don't believe in dating i actually i'm
gonna go home
i liked i liked your guys date though it
was very you guys got into it very quick
which is common in lesbians
it was a very u-haul date
what did you write on in your notes yeah
i wanted to know too i was looking uh
u-haul energy
and galentine's day
that's all valentine
and six more times
valentine's
uh so have you ever been on a date with
a woman or did they not allow that in
missouri
okay first of all i lived in tampa for a
very long time but no i've only dated
men
i'm boring boring i know simon what's
here
you you've not dated men right or you've
not dated women right
no i have not dated where are you from
ethnically then oh i'm pakistani okay
yeah they don't really do that over
there
pakistan has the highest number of gay
porn
down
fundamentalists they love gay porn
they're trying to figure out who to get
right
they love a walk on the naughty side
but uh yeah so how long have you been uh
do you have an immigrant parent and are
they very like
understanding of your polyamorous
lifestyle
uh they only want me dating muslim men
so oh
and you know how many muslim men are in
austin texas let's set her up with fuzzy
we know a muslim man
he's attractive
they're not very fun
oh fuzzy's the bad boy
yeah he'll eat pork if you know what i
mean
i wouldn't want
pork
anyways
do they you eat pork in missouri or
wow
freaky
kids are cold
cats and corn and pork
come to missouri
sima is a vegetarian and she's dating a
white man she's just double
disappointing her father
so did your parents know that you died
white men
not yet
what uh uh what do they think that
you're doing right now
just in general
not dating
i think i don't know i don't ask or
marriage comes into arrange i don't
wanna arrange marriage to come in oh
have they tried to arrange you
yeah
back last year they my desk sent me a
screenshot of three men
without contacts no contact
i was like what is this and then i
understand he was like this one in
pakistan engineer this one
california he's very good
he's very good at all things candice
have you ever been on an arranged date
before i have not
that's right this is america
we [ __ ] whoever we want ballad
how did you meet your beautiful fiance
tinder
i know and i've been with them three
years can you imagine if you want to if
you want a marriage get on tinder get
out
get off ping ping just for losers oh
i'm kidding
i did not think that's where it was
going to go but that's where we are
so where did he take you on the first
date uh the movies the movies are you
selling victims she dates too no
i don't remember what i saw i was too
busy making out i saw his car
as an adult that's cool
how old were you when you met this man
three years ago three years ago so three
years ago in times
12 you were 12. do i look 12.
i've always learned to uh underestimate
her age yeah
that's cool you went on a movie and then
now you guys are in a movie
now aren't we no you guys are getting
married i guess weddings are stressful
as [ __ ] i only recommend it when's the
date uh 4 28 23. can i come you you seem
cool you're gonna have to pay for your
own food that shit's expensive man
can i come that's the only reason i want
it
you can come too we need more diversity
it'll be me and you not children
you're dating a white man
yeah holy [ __ ]
i was like use your white man powers for
good
thank you an ally
you're converting him with your [ __ ]
somebody else converted him i just get
to reap the benefits at this point
so he's uh
he's a lover of chocolate yes long time
lover of chocolate can you can't you
just be a lover of humans though
would you like someone's like i like
ramen
has never dropped that on you before
lemon ramen
yeah whatever it takes you know
i'm not good beggars can't be chooser
if you like me you like me you know who
am i to question why uh but would you
think you date women who might be like
really angry and like bless you around
[Laughter]
you do date small angry white women
i've noticed
yeah whatever whatever it takes i'll
i'll take a lot of emotional abuse if it
means i get laid does that mean you're
cockled it's how you say that's hot cold
i love that
yeah he's a [ __ ] sold me yeah
how about a man you know that'd be fun i
don't want to waste two women on each
other
uh
yeah why don't we have uh simon go on a
date with a man
candace is coming up after that with a
real man
we got two or three more women in the
bucket but simon is now gonna go on a
date with marshall exclamation mark
parentheses
oh this is like a semicolon
yeah
poland give it up for uh marshall and
can we get more lights just more
lights over here just light it up simon
yeah there we go
we got marshall going on a date with
sima give it up for marshall and sima
hello
how long have you been in austin for
since the end of february so you're one
of those i'm one of those
where did you move from you don't want
to know did you move from california it
wasn't san francisco we gotta go back
i'm not from there though that's a
problem i'm originally from north
carolina
you should go back
i don't want to go back there either
that's a problem too high now so it's
your fault
i think you should go to north carolina
oh no that's where the rain's cheap now
apparently everybody's going there
there's nothing fun there that's not
it's not true so why did you move down
here then
there's more fun stuff here
what do you like to do for fun
um
i don't know the past couple weeks i've
just been doing all kinds of stuff went
to some concerts
now to comedy show
who'd you who'd you go see live
uh jacob collier
oh he's pretty cool
but yeah no i was on a date that time to
set up
how'd it go
it was interesting
how so
she was
already
involved with someone and i didn't know
i'm sorry yeah it's time
give it up for marshall and simon
marshall going on a date with a woman
who's on a date already for the second
time in austin
i didn't expect that it would happen
again so soon
this is the definition of a cockhold if
you know what i mean
listen up candace
you're seeing a cockhold in real life
uh
marshall this is one of the two fun
things that you've done in austin so far
uh what's
how is jacob collier
uh he's pretty cool i i really like him
he did he does this thing where he like
plays the crowd as an instrument it's
really cool oh nice that's sort of what
i like to think i do
um
that's cool simon you went with the very
risky move of telling a black man to go
go back where he came from
she's from pakistan she doesn't know her
racist culture
came from it's just a fun thing you'd
say to foreigners
white guy it's rubbing off on her
yeah
here is yo simon's a ball buster
slime is busting balls over here
is this is this what you do with john s
he just busts his balls
he did move here from california so i
did say he's one of those oh yeah
yeah you are from california are you
from sacramento or no i was in la before
this la the second worst place next to
san francisco
why'd you move here
i got a new job
okay what's the job
it's at a robotics startup
why is everybody here smart as [ __ ]
he goes to jacob collier concerts he's
not going to work in the fast food
industry
it's all people who are just reminding
me that it took me five years to
graduate high school
don't
army god damn it
she was in remedial math and so maybe
every year yeah um
cool anyway
marshall when did you graduate high
school
2013. 13 okay so you're
about 27 28
wow upper 20s
that's awesome
you you really are you have the energy
of like a high schooler it's great you
really do you have the voice of someone
going through puberty
i love it but yeah everything is for you
i was at a batting cage and someone
asked if i was on the high school team
they're like oh you're in college no
it looks like your face has yet to grow
into your body
but um yeah that's great simon uh what
high school did you go to you you're
from here right
i went to seven likes in houston or in
katy texas so oh [ __ ] she's texan yeah
yeah she's tough as [ __ ] she's like you
moving to my estate
you gotta be able to dodge a bullet
[ __ ]
uh so uh what what is the craziest thing
that you've seen a transplant do here
like
fall off a lime scooter
i have not seen that yet i haven't seen
oh you haven't truly lived then um i
mean i've seen i think the weirdest
things i've seen are austinite people
for for example when i went to ut my
first week i saw a man
shirtless with a velociraptor mask on
and a pentagram drawn on his chest
and he was break dancing sounds like a
cool tuesday yeah it was
a great
great weekday
that's awesome austin is weird that's
why i came here but now when did you
move here
2014. okay i was about to say you go
back what the hell
are you getting mad enough you moved
here too
oh yeah
that's she's grandfathered in cool yeah
so how was the date that you went on
with the other woman like did she tell
you when did she tell you that she was
seeing someone else
after the second time
oh she went on two dates with this woman
and then she was like actually i have a
boyfriend
she had someone not a boyfriend a
girlfriend no uh like a [ __ ] buddy oh
are they friend yeah
that's cool that's unfortunate
at least she was looking she was like oh
this guy could be a contender for me to
break people's hearts
yeah
and uh how many uh dates have you been
on in austin so far
i think three other ones yeah three well
you're really getting out there it's
only may were they off a dating app or
in person they're off the dating app
this one someone suggested so
who was this friend i think he was
trying to prank you
what uh what kind of woman do you go for
alive
oh
i would [ __ ] hope
now interested
oh yeah okay
and what kind of things are you
interested in oh like they're interested
in oh right they're interested in you so
if they have a pulse and they show any
interest you're down
give it a chance right yeah what if it
was a child
got to update the rubric i guess
yeah exactly
it's [ __ ] up
legal i said it but
i stand by it no but really you don't
have a type at all
[Music]
fat skinny blonde redheads stop me at
any point um like we can both fit in a
boat together
like you've seen the office boat ready
fat phobic
you wouldn't date a fat girl
i have to be able to like squat her like
in case of emergency
luckily you can squat quite a bit you
got nice thighs how much can you squat
you look like a teenager
children
i think i i pr like 225
something like that okay that's not that
much honey i made the roster
you can date two of me
um so uh simon what uh what are you
looking for in a guy what kind of guy do
you are you into
john s
basically
oh
he's one of the many that you're into
um
so what if he left
keeping tabs on him i would hate to
leave simon i feel like she would key my
car
she would keep go back to where you came
from
[Laughter]
john goes back to
europe
um simon what did what do you think
about uh going on a date with someone
who is like
muslim
like what would you do with a muslim
person go to go to the mosque
go to the airport
she likes it she's laughing
oh my tie
oh
have you ever brought a man home to your
parents
it was a muslim man oh yeah so you have
dated a muslim in college
i'll try anything in college
it said okay let me let me try something
different than my type and then i was
like no
no but you but you got to the level of
bringing him home or you just brought
him home to be like look see
i'm not dating white man both things for
me but
i i think just like the cultural values
were pretty instilled like being
controlling
just like he was just very religious so
you're just not even
okay you're a feminist
no
what
yes but like
to an extent i guess yeah what about
just feminists
what about a black muslim
marshall put on a bow tie you might be
able to be taken home to her parents
um marshall what's your religious
affiliation
i was raised christian
evangelical or a protestant or catholic
southern southern baptist oh you're from
north carolina
and now you are a tech bro your religion
is bill gates
money
that's good to know the future is in
good hands
uh and uh sima you said you would not go
to north carolina north carolina is
pretty dope
i wouldn't move there
well no one would move there
yeah visit you know charlotte
uh where are you from charlotte
charlotte yeah charlotte's a good the
only city there
you could go there what do you do for
fun in charlotte go to the comedy zone
or
leave charlotte no leave charlotte
what a what an ambassador
go hiking you can't do that anywhere
else but charlotte
um you know it's asheville
asheville's great cooler city yeah yeah
so uh what what would you say to sima to
get her on board
with a second date with you
like any anything cool cool facts that
you could tell say hey i can bench press
here
i don't think i fit the type i i
wouldn't even bother you're not muslim
you're in bro you gotta have confidence
that's all you need
be like i love jesus christ
simon what would you say to uh marshall
to like let him know that uh you know
you're you're
interested you're ready to go
uh
let's hang out let's hang out
marcia
you're in
all right you know sign up for a rolodex
she's got a lot of people in there but
you could be one of them
sonical i mean
i don't want like you're cool i gotta be
friends i've heard that before it's fine
he works in tech he's used to the friend
zone
uh where would you guys go on a date you
think
the library
i i have a list of restaurants to try
over austin so usually i pick one off
the list and then what was the
restaurant john s said zanzibar or
is on your list yeah i haven't been
there yet though oh say okay yeah you
could take him her there
anyways give it up for this beautiful
couple
marshall and sima
i miss candace
candace was coming up right now
candace you're going on a date with a
real-life man you're not engaged to
yeah give it up for mike linehan
mikey
mickey
i think mike left mike
mike is a stand-up comedian who uh does
not keep his dates
uh
mike linehan is not here so he candice
is going on a date with rameen
lamine in the house another stand-up
comedian
very funny man been on the show two
times before give it up for ramin and
candace thank you
hey candace how are you doing i'm good
oh good good did i see you uh
documenting this event no i was gonna
but then they were like no flash
photography
got you um so you have a fiance you're
engaged yeah i do i shouldn't have led
with that huh so there's really no point
in us doing this so are you single let's
talk about you
sure yeah i'm a single man
i'm a great winged woman i really am ask
my friends who would you set me up with
um can't see them they're all just white
spots wait till later but i got two
great friends back there we're all
nurses it's nurses week thank us you're
welcome
been dying out here and coving and [ __ ]
i was actually hoping you could set me
up with which you can john s jonas that
doggy white piece of white curse
think you like his date
star wars fight the sima
so what's your type let's start there
um
i don't know i don't really have a type
i like to keep an open mind yeah
all lanes open
to whoever was up here just a second ago
say what you like
set the ball
what can you say i don't know i mean
you're a nice gentleman you're a
comedian right women love that [ __ ] it
should be easy for you
yeah
i'm a handsome man i do well it's time
candace and
rameen
she's gassing him up she's she's like
your life coach i know i need more any
more casting in my life is it cassie
candace candice okay names are tough
candace candace
you still look like a tech bro though i
am in tech sales actually also in the
entry level so we do have that in common
that's why i'm just saying and our
parents both want us to take brown
people so that's also something in
common
the indian friends same problem she has
to like keep everything separate and
secret i wish i was in an arranged
marriage it would be so much easier
it doesn't sound bad it would take all
the stress guidelines absolutely that's
sort of what this show is it's arranged
dating
no i'm not muslim dude
you're not muslim apparently play along
god
maybe ask me next week i might change
but uh we'll see
zoroastrianism so you worship the eagle
yeah
kind of close you actually know a little
bit about him i'm impressed i have a
tattoo on my back yeah
okay he's got a tattoo
that's cool is it a poem is it like 17
stanza no it's the eagle it's the eagle
the man eagle holding the ring no that's
great we all need to worship the eagle
more i think that's what's wrong with
societies i agree i don't respect the
eagles
[Laughter]
how the [ __ ] did he get roped into this
[ __ ] i uh i i don't know i think he just
felt bad because i got wasted on his
podcast last time you're asked to be on
this ship on this yeah did tonight yeah
it's on right now it's on the video
rameen what's the how many dates have
you been on
in austin yeah
a few a handful
so you've been on a handful of paddle
boards
i've actually only been paddle boarding
once in austin yeah but do other things
yeah you gotta you gotta go paddle you
got a lime scooter to a paddle board
what's with you and paddleboarding what
do you like it's like the second time he
brought it up so what him and his
girlfriend do right you guys
it's like the perfect mix of a boat and
you know like surfing
so well closer the better
candice tell us more about your fiance
okay oh
you hear myself okay now i can uh
let's see he's very different for me
i'm uh not a big gun person and he's a
huge gun person and i was like oh red
flag but he's cool he's like responsible
going on for so you're like a red flag
perfect this is the perfect man to talk
about yeah exactly exactly what i need
yeah no so are you in love
absolutely why else would you get you
can just in love
guys come on a round of applause i need
more out of you i need more out of you
for lots of reasons but yes i like love
him he's wonderful yes to me but
everybody's different right yeah he's
not nice too for nerds we
like he's not nice to animals or targets
he's shooting hoes but he's nice he
doesn't yeah
okay but don't do you eat meat i love me
well there you go yeah you're not nice
to animals no i'm not
uh but i like talking about setting you
up i like that i said what's the last
time i'm good on the day go on a date
tonight son oh he said i appreciate your
help
young brown man i can do pretty well for
myself huh i want to see the lady you're
going on a date with pull up a picture
yeah
no wow
because if you're being filmed and
that's fair i'm not like a
guy
after the show i'll show you all right
cool
rameen
you seem very serious
god i'm just i'm just like
i'm fun
that's what i like to do for fun i'm out
here trying to find love i can see why
simon doesn't date muslims yeah
yeah that's it i mean you guys seem like
a very interesting couple i feel like
you would come home and you know you
would be like happy and he'd be like
like what why are you happy
i'm a very good looking brown man i
don't need you you better get it
together
that's exactly what i would say and how
it would sound
like yours
what is this casserole
they're pork in this
candace would have all the uh macrame
and all the knitting done
on it
okay no i don't do any of those candice
if you have a piano why are you on this
dating show it's fun it is fun are your
friends signed up
this many people at this show to be
honest so good for you so i figured it
would be me and my three friends
okay for more women
cons how do you feel about that what you
just said that's real great you know so
what do i know you know
doing great candice oh i mean i'm just
doing me you're the [ __ ] star of the
show candace
candace is in love everybody
as hell here i'm running away i don't
know why you all oh yeah you're going
home yes i'm going home
yeah back to the frozen tundra here just
till monday oh okay yeah where's home
missouri missouri missoula or
mom i mean just depends some people call
it missouri but it's well what city in
missouri st louis
oh city i'm not from there either okay
i'm scared
and i'm a strong black woman
i'm like it's getting dark here time to
go home and the brunch is over so uh
what do people do in missouri for fun
just like eat raccoons and [ __ ] cells
they're super christian and so annoying
and i am christian and i say that and
i'm just like every time i'm a nurse
everybody walk in the room do you love
jesus
simon just thought simon just got wet
right now
she loves a good evangelical
i don't know it's not fun
yeah they have the highest murder rate
and then yeah louis absolutely don't go
there no no no no we did not we were
never gonna do that
none of us have booked a ticket
but i'm an oncology nurse and they have
very good oncology care there so that's
why i'm there is that are you having
your wedding there no where are you
having it kansas kansas city where my
partner's from oh that's also here
you guys are just doing a tour of all
the broken down midwest cities
ohio
we're not wrong
uh that's cool uh rameen when are you
getting married when are you gonna make
your zoroastrian parents proud yeah
whenever my parents find me someone
who's suitable
a little something but no i don't know
whenever it happens it's life it's hard
to find love it's it's tough
but we're trying especially with those
eyebrows listen i'm just going to keep
coming here every week
one time it'll happen you have scary
features i could see
i could see you dating a very scary
woman and i would love that for you but
you also me too they're really scary
women i love all women i told you i'm a
glutton oh my god
what if you can't squat them do you
still like them yeah
if i can't squat them yeah
if they can't fit in a boat
that's
i don't know what to say i don't know
yeah that's so awful women are cool i
like vaginas plus size women
yeah they're fun sometimes besides
vagina it's cool cool what's your body
count
we're not talking about the people you
killed in interrogations
um
nice islamophobia
um my body count i don't know i kind of
stopped keeping count after college or
after college it's not that i can't
count to like seven so that's why
college is a place of higher learning
you don't need to count after that yeah
exactly you got a real ahmadinejad
energy
saddam hussein energy
this [ __ ] bin laden energy right here i
need a woman who really blow my world up
you know what i'm saying
ravine you are about to get an extra pat
down so it means [ __ ] yeah anything to
put someone put their hands on me
that guy got it
thank you my man over there pointing at
the audience
just be a contestant i'll better leave
right now
this is not going to end well for any of
you if you stay in the building
have you had any uh interesting
experiences with tsa uh yeah my whole
family's been patted down and searched
classic profiling white america gotta
love it
you just take it in stride and just move
forward and keep your head up high and
[ __ ] it whatever it doesn't matter go on
dates go on dates comedy shows with
candace
you are so annoying
wait uh what was i gonna ask
you ever been with a man
why did every woman call some
bill
[Laughter]
no i haven't been with a man were you
like hoping for me to say yes little bit
gay that's so disappointing everyone's a
little bit gay a little bit racist it's
just about degrees
give it up for rameen and candace
the woo master
we got two men and two women coming up
rameen
from
persia
taking a seat
uh yeah i mean you know we recorded this
right you don't need to record it
yourself
uh we got one woman coming up i'm
guessing oh no uh back there yeah
give it up for rameen one more time
he's trying to take my job like
he really
give it up for a candy or candace
it must be related to emmy because
that was okay
oh [ __ ] okay
give it up for cj hopefully this is a
woman
cj coming around the bend
going on a date with a man named
tang
is he asian
he's a
poorly asian man
thought he'd be white but he's an asian
man
representing us proudly is ting a
diverse chef and tj
how's it going it's going real it's
going pretty well i'm with like a bunch
of my friends so they they can
use this to uh heckle me for the rest of
my life
i'm sure i'm sure they will yeah how
long you been in austin for um my whole
life pretty much your whole life yeah
yeah yeah so you were born here or you
were born in austin
well me too tonight really but not
didn't grow up like uh grew up in
arkansas where it's real boring so you
do a lot of stupid [ __ ] in arkansas yeah
yeah and then came back
never left you should go back oh
if i go back uh they're likely to shoot
me
uh
you know you know the exclusive store of
amazon you know it's like you know
it's very rare
the fruit shorts
yeah yeah i couldn't get the fruit
shorts in time so like you know black
really short see
um
but yeah
what are they all up to tonight um
what the [ __ ] are we up to uh you know
there's always something random that
goes on like we just bought like a um
a walk like a water slide
so like basically you didn't you know
you could you could connect it to the
hose and it just like just just splashed
water on you and time
give it up for cj and ting
uh you're the very definition of the uh
smartphone game fruit ninja over here an
asian man wearing a fruity shirt
uh dang you got a water slide
what are you in a frat
we have a we have a house that talk
directly put it right there we have a we
have a house that we call
fun house because we did like a cook
night there one time but like basically
we just always hang out there and they
have a hot tub and
you're like you know it's it's it's real
hot outside right now so we were like at
target it was like
let's just get a lot of slimes
wow uh
a grown man
who
buys a water slide and uh has that
t-shirt
this is the very definition of austin
right here
this is you're the mascot for our city
ting i don't know if you're proud of it
angle but he has a ponytail
[Laughter]
hopefully the water can put out her fire
tricks that she's got going with yeah
hopefully uh you can just wet the water
slide with all the [ __ ] from yeah
all the ladies in austin cool
cj uh
what do you do uh where do you live and
uh i'm a men's hairstylist i own a men's
salon
mental salon so you deal with men every
day you you whip them into shape
what do you think about the
the whatever is on what's going
whatever's going on top of tim's head
right now she's dying to cut it off
outdated a little bit it's called an
undercut we don't it's like two he's got
two different haircuts going on but
he looks like a karen now
he looks like he's about to ask for the
manager
that's a bob
you do pull it off though you're kind of
like uh like uh some like a
like a tropical asian
i was trying to figure out a country i
couldn't get there anymore i don't get
that under 10. yeah no i'm just saying
without the undercut is like ball's hot
like i can't i can't deal with it is it
like uh sort of an asian thing
it's like a
mri top knot so for the longest time i
had like just the short hair and like
spike right right up here that spiked in
the front and um
uh because of pandemic i was like all
right let's see how long i can grow this
yeah for two years is just like down
here yeah you went from uh normal asian
to hipster asian yes that's uh i decided
to you know it's a good transition like
maybe i'll make more money that's the
hipster asian
that's wonderful a lot of us are you
know play by the rules and you're out
here wearing watermelon shirts and
cutting your own hair
uh
cj what uh what do you think about uh
austin uh you you're from here right
yes
and uh you love it here you love
eeyore's birthday did you recently go to
that at peace park
no but my
my daughter went to oh you have a
daughter
what is she
oh 16 yeah is she a [ __ ]
yes
we all are at that age
no i've done all that stuff all the
yours and all the festivals and all that
stuff and it's just it's everything's
too busy and crazy here now but i still
love it and you know gotta love
dizziness when you have a
where would you go with uh ting to on a
date paddle boarding or
no definitely not and
it doesn't look very floatable
i don't want to see that ponytail wet
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
it's a cliche date
i mean one time i heard that there was a
vampire sex club here but i think it
closed down from covid yeah they're
talking to each other
awesome jokes
isn't it right around the corner yeah
that's right around the corner
do you get that joke means you've been
it means you're a weirdo welcome to
awesome
beautiful bar
infested with rats
okay
throwing shots
pick ladies on first deities
uh
it kind of depends um you know like um
i like if i like if they like games or
something like that like pinballs was
one date another one was like uh
paddleboarding uh
no um
it's just kind of like if there's an
event going on like just kind of like
just something that's fun that's like
more interactive like that you can like
you can actually not not a movie or
anything like that because like no one
talks you want to be able to like just
say yeah or you could make out
with your team
that is the other option
engaged
but you're an austin weirdo you're not
looking for commitment
i've been almost been married like twice
so like like oh you are asian
what do your asian parents think about
you
are you half asian i'm half asian okay
i'm taiwanese and um the other half is
like scottish and like other white
yeah but but uh you know my my mom wants
me to have a kid
uh as all asian parents do and like
she's at the point now where she doesn't
care if i have a partner she's just like
this time
just steal one this like this time in
nine months i want you to have a kid i
was like
wait what what girl
who where am i going to pregnant am i
gonna steal a kid like you know
cj uh what uh how did you uh have a baby
what is it what is that what do you
think
he had set
normal
was it ivf or
epidural normal organic how much did it
cost
normal she had sex before wow
what uh what happened to the baby daddy
he's here but he's here we're not
together oh okay
no he's not in this room oh he lives in
austin he's the owner of elysium that's
why you're throwing a shirt
she released the rats
he's a rat
um that's great you have a beautiful
child together and uh she goes to high
school in austin
how does she like austin is is are there
a lot of like transplants here
she like weirded out but
i mean she we lived in houston for a
short time and she was kind of pissed at
me for coming here but
i mean who wants to live in houston
sorry sorry
like a cool mom though you look like the
mom that's like i want you to smoke weed
in like at home
and share with me yeah share with me
yeah
not gonna say
she smokes weed with her daughter
they're watching the show so you only
have one kid then
yes okay why are you in the baby daddy
split
um
i don't know it just wasn't wasn't meant
to be um
yeah so mature so mature
you ask most people they're like oh he
was a [ __ ]
whatever that's cool uh so you know
her pipes work you can put one in her
make your mom happy
is that the bare minimum
mom take a step child no
i mean oh i'm sure i'm sure she'd be
fine with it but like she'll be like i
want a blood shot yeah she wants a
nature baby
asian babies are adorable how asian is
your child
yeah caucasian or
she's full
white whatever worldwide type of repair
white powder
dated guys from all different
countries and whatever that's cool plus
he's like the u.n
colors of benetton
so have you ever dated an asian man yes
what what type of asian
like
it was oh hong kong
mainlander
singapore
her mic cut out there we go i was in my
twenties
well that was when trump was president
so
no just kidding
uh no i'm sure he was asian you know
more asian than ting i'm sorry ting no
you're asian
thing uh so have you ever been to taiwan
yes like uh used to you i actually grew
up there so like every two years oh you
grew up in how old were you when you
moved because that's really important
well the thing is like uh like the first
english very good
it is very good we come back
can i do it
it's mexico uh but like it's like
well we would live over there for like
uh like a few months and then come back
over here and then damn you're more
asian than i am
do you have one of those uh white dads
that like got like snatched one you know
that's what my dad did
uh no no no my dad went it's like going
to taiwan to import the import my mom
from
the u.s are they still in love still
together yeah they're still together
holy [ __ ] they they now do work
woodworking together and learn spanish
and i'm like
like and then they they have a mexican
child they're like we might as well go
full mexican
they they bring the what they make and
they leave it at my house and i'm like i
have no room here why why is it
like i have like three chairs that i
don't need
it's for your wife and your baby
give it up for ting and cj
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out
give it up for adult kiddo heather key
you got anything coming up you want to
plug
uh
not really
hungover
i'm not hungover
uh this uh show happens every sunday at
six uh thank you guys so much for coming
out give it up for yourselves thank you
very much have a good night
royalty free music
[Music]
yes
oh
weird right
oh she does just wondering
oh
oh good thank you